[Music]  it's you I'm in trouble here I'm need  for backup  ah that's a no can do buddy all our  birds need your fuel in the last care  package just left  [Music]  how many doggone soldiers who have to  kill to make something happen  I'm working on it you're not the only  hot you on the field listen here H do I  I'm almost out of bullets and duty can't  be calling any harder fine  look it's a treats ready cuz these guys  just graduated from puppy Academy what  what the hell does that mean it's deal  [Music]  thank god you're here  it's an honor to serve with you sergeant  sergeant nibbles okay here's the blanket  if you take your men and you go around  here  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]